si j'ai le sont voilà mesdames messieurs
je vous prie d'accueillir cette 161ème
vente des vins du domaine des hospices
de beaune pour l'association fédération
nationale solidarité femmes madame
jeanne balibar et madame dominique
guillien isenmann
et je vous prie d'accueillir pour
l'institut curie
monsieur pio marmaï et monsieur le
professeur alain puisieux
[Applaudissements]
et monsieur le maire de beaune qui va
venir nous aider après 10 présidé cette
vente
la 161e vente des vins du domaine des
hospices de beaune fait honneur aux
femmes
qui ont fait ou font notre institution
guigone de salins notre fondatrice les
soeurs hospitalières
marie-cécile notre aide soignante
victimes du coït 19 disparus l'an
dernier et lé 1277 femmes qui
travaillent aujourd'hui dans nos quatre
hôpitaux et 9,8 ehpad
de windsor hospices de beaune waisale
pay tribute to the women who have made
you are making hour institutions
guigone de salins aof funds deraspe et
aussi sur marie cécile lequel gilbert
victimes avca bits l'acheteur en douane
aux tubes dance event is a woman who
worked to die in a
state 80 80 nous
nous rendons aussi justice à toutes les
femmes celles en détresse que nous
accueillons aux urgences victime de
violence du seul fait qu'elles sont des
femmes
celle qui se confie à nous pour dépister
et soigner un cancer du sein celle pour
le meilleur qui prépare et vif d'une
naissance
oui on switch to just et ce tout au
women those in distress la twizy in the
emergency service victimes de valence
simply because the women
dodine à brisbane
aux quoi preparing for experiencing
childbirth
à toutes ces femmes
nous devons le respect la sécurité des
lieux serein et la meilleure part de
notre humanité
tous les women oui on respecte safety
peaceful century of
humanity
les revenus de cette vente
et des prochaines vont nous permettre
d'achever la reconstruction de notre
hôpital pour un investissement de 70
millions d'euros mais aussi dans
quelques semaines afin d'acquérir un
nouveau mammographe
628 milliards us to achieve de
reconstruction
poly9 yuixx surcroît reignoux mameri
mammographie machine
nous relevons aussi d'autres défis
le lancement du projet muséographique
pour l'hôtel-dieu retardée par la crise
sanitaire à la suite de la magnifique
exposition à laquelle je vous invite à
partir du 4 décembre
we also ti-cats par des challengers de
landshut de music project faut d hôtel
dieu dit l'ipad crysis following the
magnificent exhibition date open on
december force
mais aussi la démarche éco-responsable
inscrite dans notre dans notre stratégie
au service de la santé de tous
le domaine poursuit son engagement dans
la biodynamie
et pour toutes nos consommations à
l'hôpital nous feront désormais la
chasse aux perturbateurs endocriniens
des responsables proches des disparus
the state continuer
leur conception
les mini présence of and cry détracteurs
enfin ce millésime est à l'image de ce
que l'hôpital a vécu en 2021
un environnement hostile et à la fin
la fierté d'avoir surmonté les
difficultés
finally the edge ise réflexion en boîte
with respect to experience in 38 38
reste à l'environnment un habit and gay
pride of having a vu comme ont des
difficultés je vous remercie
[Applaudissements]
mesdames et messieurs bienvenue d'abord
un petit mot d'accueil personnalisée il
est vrai que c'est pour nous la
nouveauté nous avons depuis la preuve
pour la première fois depuis 160 ans
était choisi la maison sotheby's ses
services pour être l'opérateur de la
vente des hospices et nous remercions le
directeur des hospices de beaune et
toute la la ville de beaune pour pour ce
choix c'est un ça nous oblige évidemment
et toutes les équipes derrière cécile
bernard la directrice mondiale des
opérations ont été mobilisés comme vous
le savez depuis maintenant plus de six
mois je crois que la bonne nouvelle est
tombée en mars dernier je dois vous
faire maintenant quelques éléments
d'annonce légaux et puis nous
commencerons la vente avec le numéro un
nous sommes heureux de vous accueillir
donc dans la grande halle de baudoux
selon l'agrément 2001 002 du 25 octobre
2001 nous procédons aujourd'hui dimanche
21 novembre 2021 à la 161e vente des
vins des hospices de beaune
nous attirons votre attention sur les
conditions de vente et vous prions d'en
prendre connaissance dans les
informations acheteurs figurant dans le
catalogue ces informations précise
notamment les montants des commissions
d'achat des frais généraux et des frais
des futailles que les acheteurs devront
payer en sus du prix marteau
conformément à l' usage la pièce des
présidents sera exempté de ses frais et
de ses commissions nous invitons
également nous vous invitons à consulter
les avis affichés sur les tableaux
d'information
le commissaire priseur qui dirige la
vente déterminera le prix la mise à prix
initiale de chaque lot il pourra porter
des enchères au nom et pour le compte du
vendeur jusqu'à ce que le prix de
réserve soit atteint
je serais aujourd'hui accompagné de ré
limaces ou et d'aurélie van de voorde et
nous nous relèverons tout au long de
cette vente et je recevrai également des
enchères de la salle des pôvres qui
seront prises par mes collègues james
reid et jonas t bide
un petit mot enfin sur la faculté de
multiplication nous vous rappelons que
les pièces mises en vente sont présentés
par qg toutes les pièces du même cuvée
ont un contenu identique chaque pièce
constitue un lot à l'intérieur d'une
même cuvée les pièces sont regroupés en
série désigner chacune par une lettre à
l'intérieur d'une même série
l'adjudicateur d'un lot peut choisir
d'exercer la faculté de multiplication
c'est à dire il peut décider d'acquérir
tout ou partie des autres pièces de
cette série qui n'ont pas encore été
adjugés au même prix que le lot qui
vient de lui être adjugé si un acheteur
n'exerce pas cette faculté ou bien ne
l'exercent que partiellement
sur une partie donc des pièces de la
série alors le commissaire priseur met
aux enchères la première des pièces non
encore adjugé est l'adjudicataire de
cette dernière pourra de la même façon
exercer cette faculté de multiplication
sur les pièces restantes
mesdames messieurs nous ont aussi
plusieurs vous informer qu'à partir de
l'eau 115 de la pièce du président
vous aurez la possibilité d'un café sur
ma gauche dans la petite tente qui est
dressée au milieu de la salle est donc
ce sera un moment une petite pause
technique autour d'un café
dear sir madam hors piste où elle commet
outre de bonnes grande salle où air baez
à nice ou savane un droit 0 0 tout en
stratifié october to sign and one soit
vis francis tous possèdent tous des
saints des gentils forces nouvelles tout
ça en zone 30 i want to the one aurait
ainsi dit fort hospices de beaune why
there from la toile tout l'ofc trois des
six titres ou yoan fanise drogues dures
conditions sauf celle des fonctions de
bayonne which included in de catalogue
des formations spécifiques dédiés au
monde off barrios primaire de overhead
premier abord elle fit date byers will
have to put in addition to the rameurs
price
record' into you shall practice aux
présidences baroeul will be exemple pour
10,6 en commission wilson nature comme
celle de notices posted on dîne
formation boys des actionnaires dans
wicked the same il détermine sénéchal
been for each lot des actionnaires
mesplès consécutive à deux responsables
ont bien avancé la théorie the price is
achieve aux animations d'aurélie van de
voorde roczen herlings
my side and will be good things prom
salle des pôvres james wynne jones tebib
my collègues il operate d'avec les
formes de sainte des pauvres we made you
dad barrasso ford à plus d'un titre avec
cuvée hall de barents deuxième cuvée
identical itx baroeul constituent le lot
within the same curé de borgo petite
cerise itx dignity violateurs within the
same série de succès sur bidart flotte
mais choose to exercise multiplication
up baptisée mehdi ceinture quoi alors
partovi robinson this is not have not
yet bid auction a dû scemama price of
the watchtower ima il fait d'ailleurs
daz note exercise us open on y parlait
use it dioxines et où il obtient deux
faces b hunter chase and the winner is
there will be et bolton exercise
multiplication options for the meaning
based in de service ladies and gentlemen
for the first time 18h louis lave wild
bunch of coffee right after leurs trois
neurones sixtine in the middle of the
road my left et nous démarrons les
enchères
maintenant après cette annonce un peu
longs ongles avec le lot numéro un
le numéro un
avec un nombre total de beaune 1er cru
cuvée des dames hospitalière l'accueil
16 pièces ont tous que nous divisons en
série en 4 séries a b c ont démarré que
le lot numéro un et je suis déjà 6500
euros moins cher cette nuit vous êtes
plusieurs 7000 8000 8000 sur ma droite
9000 au mieux de la sole dix mille dix
mille au fond 11000 monsieur vers le
milieu 12000 sur la droite 2013 mais le
parvis gilles cgil à 13000 qui couve
leur chair de 13000 14 milles derrière
vos gilles parent voilà quinze mille par
gilles 15000 barge il s'est déjà pris
relancer puis repris par gilles vous en
voulez 16000 sur la droite seize mille
sur la droite dans la seule qui couvre
la recherche de 16000 euros sinters ces
machines tard zones urbaines 17000 17000
au milieu par joue alain à 17000 euros
qui coule enchères de 17000 ses 28 une
phase on est 1914 à 17 milles qui
couvrent l'enchère de 17000 c'est votre
cher alain à 17 milles qui couvrent
l'enchère de 17000 et nihat 26 internet
s'imagine pas et lionel bieder 17000
dans la seule on est juge à 17 millions
dernière chance c'est votre enchère
lundi 7000 last chance
17000 à l'acheteur numéro
vous prenez 109 et vous prenez quatre
ans tout monsieur ou 4 additionnel 4 ans
tous merci beaucoup c'est d'ailleurs
toute la série au même prix à 17000
euros un acheteur 109 1 merci beaucoup
quatre lots en tout fort launch into
john jennyfer flotte
thank you very much
la série b toujours beaune 1er cru cuvée
des dames hospitalière et on redémarre à
nouveau à
5512 me
qui est à 15000 si vous alain cazes
ville au fond de la salle 43 15000 16000
au fond de la salle à 16000 monsieur
17000 ses 20e pas combien
17000 sur ma droite a dit 7075 à 17
milles qui couve l'enchère de 17000
c'est vous monsieur à 60 à 17000
monsieur vous souffriez votre paddle
vous voulez dire un autre c'est vous à
17 milles ça vous va 17000 qui couvrent
l'enchère de 17000 euros c'est un titre
à zone à 17 mais jade juges six
personnes le couple enchères qui couve
l'enchère de 17000 plus vous informer
cieux à certaines zones i'm telling
17000 je vous laisse juge attendez avant
avoue 17000 monsieur vous en prenez deux
autour de additionnel 2 ans tous merci
beaucoup les deux donc l'hôte number
five n 6
kate file en 6 soldes ou pas soldes
amber à 17000 aux 75
pas dans nos moeurs inventif arrive
toujours beaune 1er cru la cuvée des
dames hospitalière la série c
est le lot numéro 9 vous avez dit que
moi 15 min par le 43 à 15 mai
à 15000 seize mille merci monsieur 16000
dans l'allée vers l'avant à 16000 euros
17000 contre vous monsieur 17000 vous
voulez plus c'est dans l'allée à gauche
18000 par vosges il à 18000 par gilles à
18000 monsieur dans la halle et non 18
milles séparent rouge il à 18000 qui
couve à l'enchère de 18000 euros et
insider bill clinton
à 18000 euros pas de regret à 18000 jade
jugent ces vigiles c'est pas dans le
réseau la salle
avoue 18 mille acheteurs numéro je
voudrais voir le nombre d'acheteurs s'il
vous plaît 157
18 1157 c'est ça
merci beaucoup 18000 combien on voulait
vous monsieur vous l'exercez le un seul
merci beaucoup un supplément témoins ont
tous
un an tous d'accord le numéro 10
toujours de beaune 1er cru
numéro vite absolument et nous démarrons
ici à saray convient
seize mille merci monsieur pour lui mi
temps 16 mille
dix sept mille merci monsieur enfin dans
la salle monsieur dans l'allée voulait
en venir dont dix sept mille euros par
tonne sur le même prix à 17 milles qui
couve à l'enchère de 17000 euros c'est
au milieu vers le fond de la salle à
17000 c'est vous monsieur face à moi pas
de regret à 17000 jade juge
voulait pas venir 18 milles
sur 17 lille à 17000 on est à 17000 pas
de regret à 17000 euros on renonce 17000
euros dernière chance jade juge à 17000
acheteurs 43 voulez-vous le lot suivant
monsieur vous n'en prenez caen
n'a plus qu'à bien sûr us et le 8 merci
la troisième série toujours beaune 1er
cru cuvée des dames hospitalière et nous
démarrons le numéro 9 une pièce à 6000
euros 17000 à nouveau à 17 me parrainer
du temps combien 18 me
non il ya dix sept mille des gens
17000 déjà dans l'allée ses prix il faut
dire 18000 sinon je ne prends port qui
couvrent leur chair de 17000 euros
rapidement monsieur aux fonds non à 17
milles marianne vous aviez l'air de
tentes et dix sept mille euros adjugent
lorgere est prise à 17000 on renonce à
17 millenia devance on se met une tenue
rose et ni advanced online services
intelligence
à vous monsieur 17 mille acheteurs 113
merci beaucoup et je vais vous demander
combien vous en voulez 2
donc oui wanna die schöne lot no berthen
toulouse une tôle toujours à 17 milles
et nous démarrons nous continuons avec
le numéro 11 toujours bonne premiers
crus toujours dans la série c'est le
numéro 11
combien
20-14 14001 quinze mille merci monsieur
sait si vous êtes plusieurs derrière dix
sept mille mercis que dit-on derrière à
17000 son milieu de la sole sundin
phrase que dit-on fond de la salle à
17000 personne ne bouge en chair de 17
mille euros c'est vers le milieu de la
salle
dernière chance mesdames messieurs au
fond de la salle c'est au milieu à 17000
jade juge 17000 euros pas de regret dans
le fond à 17 milles à 17000 dernière
chance et vous romain je crois 17000 à
17000 que des tons
17000 euros au milieu acheteurs 64 merci
beaucoup à 17 milles est ce que vous
prenez voilà reprenez le suivant donc le
11 et le 12 toulotte swan a dit shawn
hall of key à 17000 toujours et c'est la
chair 53 c'est ça
64 pendant
merci beaucoup
nous passons à la série dès maintenant
toujours des cuvées des dames
hospitalières quinze mille déjà lors cac
17000 pour vous départager messieurs
18000 le sang neuf non dit cette milice
et lens 18 mille merci monsieur qu'une
chemise jaune à 17 18 euros peut-être
pas jaune pardon
18-18 une mission claire à 18000 que
dit-on à 18000 euros et in st urbain de
back of the night in san jose à 18000
qui tous boulangère de 18000 monsieur
avec un masque du gym il face à moi au
fond de la salle jette juge à 18000
dernière chance c'est vous monsieur à
18000 ennemis a dit vince neil stein
online à 18000 euros pas de regret c'est
vous monsieur face à moi 18 me à juger
vous en prenez un train plus waza en
tout un an tout votre numéro d'acheteurs
s'il vous plaît 18 mille acheteurs 211
merci beaucoup one law a tonné le numéro
17000 déjà qui colle enchères de 17000
j'ai vu d'abord monsieur au fond voulait
pas dire 18
17 milles au fond de la salle à 17
milles
à 17000 nous sommes à 100 intron à 17000
que dit-on à 17000 pas de regret à 17
milles à 100 in thailand
à 17000 euros on renonce à 17000
junile
à 17,8 euros au fond de la salle a dit
cette dernière chance à 17000 euros on
renonce à 17
17 mille euros monsieur à l'acheteur 109
vous en voulez combien monsieur en tout
une seule d'accord on passe au lot
numéro so jazz soul funk et jazz au loin
note
numéro 15
17 lille tout de suite par monsieur dans
l'allée à 17000 kiko blanchard de 17000
vous envoler ont sur leur droite a dit
c'est plus drôle est face à moi
dix-huit mille merci beaucoup
à dix-huit mille euros c'est votre
enchère à 18 à 18 milles qui comblent
enchères de 18 mille au téléphone à
18000 euros yobi les datacenters à 18000
à 18000 pas leur gré jade juge à 18000
euros sur ma gauche dernière chance pas
dans la salle et états unis reviennent
aux
118 mille acheteurs elle 00 16
ou du like the auction
oniwon
le numéro 16 maintenant dernier lot de
la série 17 lycées sur la trt du sap et
17000 ici qui couve l'enchère de 18
mille merci monsieur
non discipline j'ai pas pris les cinq
sens on peut pas les prendre 17000
voulais tu me quittes ou blanche à 18000
par gide à 18000 par gilles merci gilles
à 18 mai et jean case un mur build and
the back of the writings
par vigil 18000 que dit-on à 18000 euros
c'est sur la droite plus dans le réseau
la salle et jade juge à 18000 dernière
chance personne à nine attitude tarzan
news
18000 gilles vous me donnez numéro
d'acheteurs s'il vous plaît
numéro
157 merci beaucoup
donc fini la série t et nous démarrons
maintenant
pour marc premier cru la cuvée des dames
de la charité
et nous démarrons
avec
on démarre le no 10 est absolument
de la série a et nous démarrons le
numéro 17 dix mille onze mille euros sur
double commission aux mid douze mille
enfants 12000 13000
17000 ici monsieur quatrième en dix sept
mille mercis 18 milles derrière ben 10
9019 file au fond de la salle qui couvre
la recherche de 19000 euros vingt mille
merci messieurs à 20000 euros soit 10 à
22 milles au fond de la salle à 22000
vous anglais 24 à 22 milles euros c'est
au fond à gauche dans la salle a tous
raison d'y aux toits du tout ça à 22
milles contre vous en ligne à 22000
euros qui couvre la chaire de 22 mille
personnes au delà de 22000 euros
dernière chance à 22000 liste au fond à
gauche dernière chance last chance à toi
tu tout ça sans nuire aux jade juge
adjugé 22000 est ce couple est donné le
numéro d'enchérisseur à 22000 euros à 22
milles s'il vous plaît votre numéro
d'enchérisseur au fond à gauche
il me faut le numéro rapidement
philippe vous me donner le numéro
vous aviez une enchère
revient à 20000 sinon si j'ai pas le
numéro d'enchérisseur philippe à vous
l'avez
vous pouvez leur montrer monsieur s'il
vous plaît soyez gentils parce que vous
êtes loin
c'est pas leur chair
[Musique]
alors amis excusez nous mais qu'est ce
que vous en voulez vous en voyez pas au
fond mais non on est à vingt mille
contre vous prochain gère 22 me donc
c'est ici tant pis à messieurs adjugé
vingt mille 20 milles vous montrez votre
numéro vous en prenez deux mais j'ai
besoin de votre numéro d'enchérisseur
lot numéro 60 le 17 et 18 to launch into
tall fort vingt mille euros à 20000
euros
numéro 19
lautner nineteen et nous démarrons ici
en rouge mais lille à nouveau onze
minutes sur commissions qui couvrent
l'enchère
12000 rapidement 13014 1015 1016 me
18000 à haute voix 20 me dix neuf mille
vingt mille merci beaucoup vingt mille
qui couvrent l'enchère de 20000 euros à
20000 euros ici 20 oui philippe robin
22000 monsieur à 22000 euros face à
moissy vous monsieur auclair avant 2006
vous à 22h juge à 22 villes vers le fond
de la salle face à moi touati toussaint
à vous monsieur acheteurs 211 c'est ça à
22 millions merci beaucoup combien en
prenez vous monsieur
insolent merci le 19 maintenant
le vin pardon et nous démarrons à 20000
rapidement 20000 pour le vin
22000 sauce 20007 ici l'enchère
à 20000 prochain enchères à 22 milles
en charge aravane 2000
à 20000 euros at one piece 1,2
à 21 me à 21 milles à 21000 rapidement
qui couvrent longère de 21 euros
à 21000 euros sur ma droite l'enchère 21
min à 21000 euros dernière chance à
21000 jade juge at what you want a pas
de bananes pas d'enchères sur le net à
21 milles sur la droite
21000 est-ce que je peux avoir votre
numéro d'enchérisseur 75 à 21000 euros
pour le numéro 20
nous passons à la série b toujours des
cuvées de la cuvée des lames de la
charité et le numéro 21 une pièce donc
compte 20000 déjà tout de suite
à 20me le début de la salle l'enchère
est prise à 20000 euros qui couvrent
l'enchère de 20000 euros rapidement à
20000 euros à 20000 euros et on peut
prendre 21000 pour être sur le même pied
à 20000 euros rapidement à toi titre à
san jose à 20000 euros vingt mille que
dit-on à 20000 vous avez 21000 mais il
sait philippe à 21000 une dame au fond
de la salle à 21 milles qui coule
enchère de 21 mille mêmes enchères que
précédemment à 21
[Musique]
1374 dernière chance 21000 madame au
fond et jade juge à vous madame 21000 et
j'espère qu'on va voir un nombre
d'acheteurs maintenant madame votre
numéro rapidement
madame
philippe s'il vous plaît sap a
recommencé est-ce que je prends un
numéro
40 merci beaucoup 21000 pour l'acheteur
numéro 40 combien on voulait vous madame
monsieur derrière qu'on lui en voulez
vous une seule merci le 22 à nouveau
alors vingt mille qui est le premier a
pris 20 min man ma dame en rouge à mamie
qui couvrent l'enchère de 20000 euros à
20000 euros vivement
accréditation rose à 20000 que dit-on à
20000 on peut prendre 21000 pour être
sur le même pied que précédemment à
20000 à 20000 jade juge madame en rouge
à 20000 euros dernière chance la chance
at what is under aux vingt mille
acheteurs 183 merci madame 1 le numéro
23 20 milles au 109 20 villes qui couve
l'enchère de 20000 euros vous les 21
villes merci monsieur à 21h toi tu vois
de temps à 21 10 21 milles vers le
milieu à 21000 euros
21000 dijon 21 midget juge
toiture-terrasse 21000 dernière chance
passe sur le net
21000 je vous recommande votre numéro
d'enchérisseur s'il vous plaît le 113
merci beaucoup le numéro maintenant
sawtche solde soit 14 et nous démarrons
avec le numéro 24 une pièce 20 villes
pour le sang neuf à 20 me à famille qui
couvrent l'enchère de 20000 21000 au
fond de la salle et vous allez chercher
le numéro s'il vous plaît philippe très
vite parce que je ne vois plus rien aux
fins des salles 21000 qui couvre la
chaire de 21 me à 21 milles at what you
want the last chance 38 ans amy adams la
nature ouattara à notre avis on renonce
21000 j'ai besoin du numéro s'il vous
plaît pardon
85 à 21 milles personnes number eight
iphone merci beaucoup
la série c'est maintenant de la cuvée
des dames de la charité et nous
démarrons les enchères à 20000 bien sûr
le premier qui dit 20000 qu'elle 109
cette fois-ci 20000 gilles g qu'on
trouve à mille est ce que la personne
que vous avez 21000
21 villes merci j'ai toit du gymnase à
21 milles ces vigiles à 21 milles qui
couvrent longère demain termine ses
bougies à 21000 euros
à 21 villes que des tons in advance une
trentaine à 21000 pas de regret à 21000
on adjugent à 21000 euros dernière
chance 21000 avoue gilles le au numéro
21 min l'adjuger au numéro
157 merci beaucoup combien en prenez
vous monsieur
un seul un le lot
26 maintenant dix-huit mille vingt mille
20 milles par 209 il faut pas jouer à ça
parce que finalement vous avez raison
d'essayer vingt mille 20 milles que
dit-on à 20000 21 mille mercis on
revient sur les mêmes pieds 21 mille
merci monsieur twenty one phase qui
couvre la chaire de 21000 qui convolent
enchère de 21 mille euros à 31 15 à 21
milles vers le milieu à 21000 que dit-on
à 21000 rapidement toiture un terrain
adjugé à monsieur 21 1913 et vous en
voulez peut-être un seul le lot numéro
20 me et madame c'est non mais vous êtes
à 20000 déjà c'est bien essayé mais ça
marche pas vingt mille par le sang neuf
c'est lui que sa s'établit comme ça
vingt mille à 20000 touati tarde donc
milieu 20000 que kiki qu'au volant cher
de 20000 rapidement à 20000 qui dit
21000 héliades 23 10 15 à 20 me
à 20000 euros pas de regret à 20000 donc
sévère rouge il va me et jade juge
à 20000 euros ces personnes d'où cette
enchère trois etarras nuire aux
20000 au numéro 109 à mille merci
beaucoup
soto cano number one only le 28
18 mille vingt mille 20 villes c'est
fini pour à 20000 c'est vous philippins
faites moi signe voilà le lot
vous mardi 41 je crois vingt mille 20
c'est une enchère monsieur vous pencher
en arrière vous avez partir avec à 20000
atlantique razowski couleur chair de
20000 euros sur le lot 28 à 20 mille
euros pas de regret à 20 millimes et
advanced 1,38 à
320 milles jade juge céline gâteau d'y
parvenir aux dernières chances
20000 adjugé à l'acheteur philippe si
vous pouvez me répéter le numéro 41
merci beaucoup vingt mille
merci monsieur donc solde du panneau
nobel for one la série des toujours des
accusés dilemme de la charité le numéro
29 une pièce 18000 20 avril merci
beaucoup 20000 c'est le 151 pour moi
parce que vous êtes plusieurs à lever la
main en même temps donc j'ai pris le 151
face à moi au fond de la salle
3 il s'est rendu aux 20000 qui coule en
chair de 20000 avec 21 mille c'est
possible qu'ils couvrent l'enchère de
20000 à 20000 euros soit dix agents du
rose 21 mille merci beaucoup le 279 à 21
milles à toi tu wentao
21000 on renonce à 21000 jade juge 21000
euros soit 14 dernière chance
21000 vous me montrez votre numéro
acheteurs 279 21 milles on voulait vous
un seul donc nous passons au numéro 30
avec 20 mine aux 151 20 milles qui couve
l'enchère de 20000 j'ai pris le 150 à
face à marc 22000 touati tout ça
times online à 38 ou 16 à 22 villes qui
couve l'enchère de 22000 euros
rapidement touati tous âges
online tout ça c'est en ligne c'est
contre la sones à 22000 euros
j'entendais vous c'est vous piot révolte
à 22 euros
ahmad de ville que dit-on à 22000
rapidement à 22000
que ni la salle à 22000 à 100 tout ça on
renonce fin 2000 sur internet et jade
juge à l'enchérisseur internet 22000
adjugé à l'acheteur
ou du lac par sort ou d'irak aînés a dit
charlotte
bailleur tout droit dans ses bottes
non so we go to the next claude turtschy
one du continent le 31 à combien
20000 monsieur 20000 ici vingt mille au
deuxième roland chaer
21 mille merci monsieur 151 21 villes
monsieur on voulait vous à 105 à 21
milles vous êtes sûr
21000 c'est vous au milieu au fond à 21
milles qui comblent enchère de 21 m et
ligne adverse online à 3
121 mille c'est vous monsieur à 21
milles au fond de la salle jade juge à
21 316
21000 dernière chance
adjugé 21 mille acheteurs
151 on voulait vous monsieur voulait
voir lot supplémentaire
ils en tout
numéro 32
20021 mine c'est vous qui l'avez le 72 à
21 milles merci monsieur 72 à 21 me que
dit-on à 21 milles à 21 heures mis sur
la droite l'enchère a choisi au hasard à
21 milles
c'est vous 21000 euros on va juger si
personne nous plonge air de 21000
adjugé 21 mille à l'acheteur
72 le vous en voulez un autre monsieur
où c'est un seul un seul merci beaucoup
le 33 1 dernier le dernière pièce de la
série
20003 dix à vingt mille euros
qui dit 21 avez vous avez raison 21000
washington à haute voix 21000
directement par un monsieur prudent au
deuxième rang 21000 à 21000 que dit-on à
21 me personne ne couvre l'enchère de
21000 toi tu as ta dernière chance 21000
ont renoncé n'y a personne on a un
tatouage vantard dernière chance avant
monsieur 21000 et vous me redonner votre
numéro d'enchérisseur s'il vous plaît le
numéro 20 merci beaucoup à 21000 euros
merci
nous passons maintenant
au vol les premiers crus la cuvée
général muto
avec onze pièces qui seront divisés en
trois séries 3 séries abc nous démarrons
la série à le numéro 34 le numéro 34 20
milles vous l'avez ses voisins qu'il
avait merci je vous fais confiance vingt
mille euros directement à 20000 euros 21
mille merci alain 21 me c'est votre
enchérisseurs 22 mai une bataille
d'enchères 22000 monsieur à droite on
voulait vous non 22000 euros sur ma
gauche à tout ça merci c'est votre engin
saint renan c'est pas vers le reste de
la salle à 21 22000 marianne gino à 22
me à banon on peut faire des milles j'ai
refusé tout à l'heure à monsieur 500
fait pas de 500 noms ont fait déjà on
peut couper les 20 22 23 mille merci
beaucoup 23 me touati street art à 23
mai
à 23 milles à 23000 euros à 23 milles
car marianne jean uno directrice
générale à 23000 euros qui couvrent
longère de 23000 pas de regret à 23000
euros et d alsace en toi tu twittes à
zuoz à 23000 mesdames et messieurs jade
juge un téléphone
23000 euros adjugée à l'acheteur elle
vous en voyez combien marianne s'il vous
plaît
marianne2 de l'eau donc 34 et 35 ou même
pris tout là-haut tinto numéro toute
sortie 6 20 milles qui comme lingère de
20 min pour le sens des 21000 rapidement
materi sur mac os 22000 22000 sur le
fond le lot 109 à 22000 euros qui couve
l'enchère de 22000 euros c'est
l'acheteur vers le fond de la salle
avant 2000 on renonce à 22000 euros
vivement 22000 euros 22000 à l'acheteur
numéro vous meurent montrer votre numéro
d'enchérisseur 22000 aux 109
pas le number one one nine merci
beaucoup la série b numéro 37 rapidement
la série v de la cuvée général muto et
l'on démarre le numéro 37 20 22000 22000
ici qui coule enchères de 22000 23000
petite fille sage à 23000 euros nous
sommes rapidement 23 me on renonce à
23000 euros vivement 23000 pas de
regrets
23000 euros à l'acheteur 113 et vous en
prenez deux monsieurs bien sûr donc le
38 vendu aussi pour 23000 euros passons
au numéro 39 22 mille euros pour le 39
rapidement qui couvrent l'enchère de 22
euros soit tout ça à 22000 euros
figement à 22000 on renonce à 22 mais
toi tu tousses à céline nos atouts du
tout sa dernière chance pas dans le
réseau la salle 22000 euros à vous
messieurs à l'acheteur numéro je m'en
prenais deux mais j'ai besoin de votre
numéro d'acheteurs 60 et vous prenez
aussi le lot 40
et vous prenez aussi le loca vente nous
passons à la série c'est toujours cuvée
du général muto le 41 le numéro 41 20
mines 20109 22000 je me blanchard 22000
euros merci monsieur 22000 que dit-on à
22000 euros à 22 mais vivement van 3000
noms ses 22 ici monsieur
non mais c'est pas out c'est moi qui
prends les enchères vous êtes plusieurs
à hurler à parler à la demande et en
chair c'est le premier que je vois c'est
monsieur qu'une chemise blanche donc la
prochaine et 23 g désolé c'est moi qui
prends l'air les enchères à 22000 euros
monsieur sur ma droite on voulait vous à
23000 au fond vous être agréable
à 22000 euros jade juge à 22000 pas de
regrets avant de me pas vous monsieur
vous renoncez
22000 euros à l'acheteur 187 merci
beaucoup on voulait vous d'autres cieux
un seul le 42e maintenant 22000 le banc
le sang neuf le 42e à 22000 22000 euros
pas de regret à 22 me on renonce à 22000
gentil tout ça
22000 euros vivement 22
1109 vous me rencontrer votre numéro
monsieur le sang neuf à 22 milles euros
combien voulez vous une seule
le 43 le 43 numéro 43
18 mille ici l'enchère à 18 milles vingt
mille 20 milles séparent vous
20022 22000 à 22 millions à 22000 euros
sur mac os lion cher 23000 au fond de la
salle 279 à 23000 euros qui couvrent
l'enchère de 23000 euros à 23000 euros
vivement quand il suit aaron 23000 a
jugé au fond à 23000 votre numéro s'il
vous plaît votre numéro d'enchérisseur
sans
merci beaucoup je vende 3175 le lot 44
maintenant l'autre ne m'a foutu faut 44
qui tombe à 44 20 mille vingt mille à
haute voix qui couve l'enchère de 22000
22000 au fond à gauche c'est vous
philippaerts 22000 non c'est devant
c'est vous c'est vous stéphanie à
vingt-deux mille pardons
stéphanie à 22000 euros à 22000 roja
juge dernière chance à toutes et tous à
jade juge à l'acheteur 64 22 mille la
série nuuk où nous continuons maintenant
avec lebron 1er cru cuvée guigone de
salins et la série 1 le numéro 45
que nous pouvons démarrer à 6500
convient à tous 12000
13000 sur la gauche 14 mai il madame
avec une main levée 14000 15000 16000 17
mai le sont douze à dix-sept mille euros
à 17000 aux l'acheteur 112 17 milles au
numéro 112
18000 trop le 26 à 18000 euros
19/10 leur line up down in case of
online et nadine son bureau ce que dit
on à 19000 euros à 19000 pas de regret à
19000 euros dernière chance 19000 on
renonce à 19000
19000 euros
à 19000 en ligne ou un acheteur numéro
bout du lac any additional lot
atteint 10,3 en or aux aînés a dit chan
au lot
non le numéro 46 maintenant à combien le
46 15 mille mercis le 91 à 15000 16000
10 17 mille 17000 face à moi 17000 à
17000 euros 18000 par vaux philippe
à 18000 euros au fond de la salle à 18
milles on renonce à du gym il pas de
regret à 18000 euros et in fine à 18h au
fond de la salle on renonce 18000 avoue
philippe 18000 euros à l'acheteur numéro
38 merci beaucoup le numéro
phillippe
36 merci et nous
passons combien de l'eau un seul
un seul le 47 maintenant
dix-huit mille à haute voix 18000 euros
vous pouvez me potel enchères à 18000
c'est vous à 18000 euros merci à 18000
euros au milieu de la salle jade juge à
18000 euros
pour le 47 à 18000 euros dernière chance
18000 à l'acheteur numéro
172 18000 euros combien de l'eau
monsieur trois lots jusqu'à la fin 48 et
49 à 18000 euros nous passons donc à la
série b le numéro 50 que 18000 le 78 à
18000 euros vivement à 18000 pour le 70
pour le lot 5 40 à 18000 euros à 18000
euros jade juge dernière chance à 18000
euros on adjugent
18000 à l'acheteur numéro 78 combien en
voulez vous monsieur
deux noms clock tower fifty fifty one on
passe son numéro 52 18 mille euros pour
le 112 18000 euros directement qui
couvrent l'enchère de 18000 euros pour
le lot 52 à 18000 euros pas de regrets
on renonce 18000
18000 au 112 et monsieur on prend 2 c 52
et 53 à 18000 euros le numéro 54
maintenant 54 18 mille ici le 91 à 18
milles sur ma droite qui comme lingère
de 18000 ses prix sur la droite vous a
le droit de continuer à 18000 euros que
dit-on à 18000 c'est sur ma droite à
18000 euros pas de regrets
18000 à l'acheteur
114 cgt patio
91 ses passes en 14 j'ai bien vu que
monsieur métais juste son paddle comme
ça le cinq ans de la série c est
maintenant numéro 55
18 mille prix
ici on appris d'abord ici 18000
dj mister cinquième rang de la salle sur
ma gauche à 18000 euros qui couvrent
l'enchère de 18000 personnes au delà de
18 euros et nyan win it in tenu aux
dix-huit mille avoue 18000 à l'acheteur
numéro 81 comprenez qu'un le 56
rapidement 18000 euros derrière le 64 à
18000 à 18000 c'est l'acheteur 64 à
18000 euros
rapidement
toine thys are you me at six ans à 3,612
and now you be nice l'acheteur 169 au
téléphone à 19000 euros atteint 14,1 du
rose c'est votre enchère à 19,6 sur bide
online du téléphone et nanjing tendue
aux dix neuf mille qui couvrent l'envers
de 19000 euros pas de regret 19000 euros
au téléphone à dix neuf mille acheteurs
numéro 169
comment prenez-vous
57 18 mille stéphanie montre-moi 64 à
18000 le 64 à 18000 euros que dit on a
dit j mille personnes là 18000 jade juge
le 64 à 18 euros dernière chance 19me
derrière vous pardon madame à 19000 pas
de regrets jade juge à vous madame dix
neuf mille euros si personne de coûts
cette enchère 19000 euros avoue
acheteuse 997 à 19 min combien on
voulait vous madame 3 vous prenez tout
la série jusqu'au 59 merci madame le
numéro
60 ce que clos la rose grand cru cuvée
cyrot chaudron et on démarre les
enchères avec pas mal d'intérêt 70 75 80
mille demandes enchères à 80 milles sur
double commission 80000 euros artisanat
et b 85 10
100 1000 une pub somme il s'était
retranché à 5110 ville pendant la
thannoise deuxième rang à 110 villes au
moins dangereux tels phase 1 sont dix
mille au deuxième enchère et jade jugea
sont dix mille euros pour cette cuvée
120 mille mercis mais monsieur à 100 à
1000 euros sur la droite que dit-on à
120 mines voulez vous revenir sous les
130 à 120000 euros pas de regret à 120
milles c'est sur ma droite
vous en voulez cent trente mille cent
trente mille six cent vingt mille ici
salies est-ce que vous en voulez ou dix
activistes auraient déjà 10 ans
cent quarante mille en ligne à 140
milles soirée x mois dans une petite
zone 6 encore de villes allant sur
l'ordinateur à 140 milles de sommes en
ligne one for teachers qui couvrent
l'enchère de 140 mille cent cinquante
mille jim et richie a trois neurones
fifi says you by jamie à 150 piste un
téléphone enchères c'est au téléphone
l'enchère à 150000 pas de regret à 159
soit si petite zone si le guen sur jamie
antoine olympique sitters jacques dubé
160000 en ligne on voulait vous jamie
ses 160 milles en ligne contre vous
jamie rapidement à 160000
you done à 3,96 tyson jade juge à
l'enchérisseur en ligne cent soixante
mille adjugé à la série soeur 3
121 160 mille merci beaucoup
la série b nous toujours couvé cyrot
chaudron et on débat on démarre à
combien
première enchère cent mille cent mille
merci messieurs à 100000 euros vivement
110000 par vous philippe à 110 mille
cent vingt mille maintenant 120 milles
en clair à 120000 euros 125 milles si
vous voulez monsieur cent trente mille
cent trente mille toujours sur ma droite
à 130000 euros
135 mille jimmy ci pourrait être sur le
même pied one thirty five o one that i
want you to fail phrase vous en voulez à
140 milles dans la seule à 135 milles au
téléphone à 135 minutes par jamie ricci
à 135 mille jade juge n' ya deux ans on
one run sorti fife à 135 milles pas de
regret dans la salle je vais adjugé
135000 à l'acheteur est le 0 0,25 merci
beaucoup le numéro 62 maintenant le 62e
la série c de la crise cyrot chaudron
zine cent mille mercis 100000 quatrième
en 110 120 mille merci monsieur à 120000
euros à son ami loin de rennes 3 titres
hard gay monsieur jamie à 120000 euros
ja du jasmin dans la salle qui couvrent
l'enchère de 120000 euros pas de regrets
sont vingt mille
ya eu
130 milles en ligne merci monsieur le
directeur à 130 me vous m'avez vite à
léger problème 130000 euros vous en
voulez sur la droite vous en voulez sur
la droite pas vous monsieur donc 130
milles en live betting at one that i
found thank you very much as toi dans le
tissage à 130000 pas de regrets cent
trente mille adjugé à l'acheteur
264 merci beaucoup et nous entamons la
cuvée charlotte dumay corton grand cru
donc trois séries la série à le numéro
63 et j'ai 18000 déjà sur orb 18000 19
mille enfants vingt mille 20 mille ici
l'engin 22000 24 mines vague 6000 le 75
28 mille
trente mille 30 villes au second rang 32
35000 le 52 35 mille euros merci
monsieur le 50 à 38 ville tranquille au
second quarante mille 40 milles par vous
monsieur ont quitté la zone urbaine 40
min monsieur avec une chemise blanche à
40000 euros pas de regret à 40000 euros
42 villes madame à 42 mille merci madame
c'est vous
laurent solly c25 8
41 villes pour 41 milles pour continuer
sur le même pied monsieur on peut
prendre quarante deux mille si vous
voulez monsieur vous en voulez non 41000
par madame
1,41 milad fond d'une tasse à 41 me juge
dernière chance à 41 mille pas de
regrets on a deux juges à vous madame
41000 vous en prenez deux mais vous avez
montré votre numéro d'enchérisseur
surtout
merci beaucoup le 176 41000 et vous
prenez aussi le 64 on passe ou 65 numéro
48 52 merci beaucoup font-ils pas
41 villes dans l'allée à 41 mille
vivement que dit-on à 41 me juge pas de
regret à 41 mille personnes couvre
41000 à vous monsieur dernier lot de
cette série le 113 merci beaucoup
la série des cuves et charlotte dumay 48
il bien sûr
41 me quarante et un mille ici au
deuxième rang qui dit-on au fond à 41
mille nous sommes fort gymnase à 41 min
pas de regret à 41 mille quarante deux
mille merci beaucoup c'est vous romain à
42000 43me avance et un cameraman si je
ne sais plus
41 villes ces quarante deux mille
pardons 42000 qui en veut pareils madame
vous allez partir avec mais c'est un
portable à 42000 pas de regrets car en
2000 à l'acheteur numéro votre numéro
d'enchérisseur s'il vous plaît
193 merci beaucoup 42000 combien en
voulez vous monsieur un seul
nous passons donc au numéro 67
41 min 6 42 kg 75 42 mille acheteurs 75
qui couvrent l'enchère de 42000 euros
vivement 42 à 40 2 me c'est vous
monsieur vers le fond de la salle à
droite 42000 adjugé à vous monsieur
42000 à l'acheteur 75 combien vous
voulez vous un seul
41 villes messieurs 4e rang 41000 42
villes avec une veste grise monsieur
deuxième rang quarante deux mille euros
qui conte l'engin de 42000 que dit-on au
fond de la salle à 42000 c'est ici
l'enchère prochain juin 43000 si vous
voulez un 42000 dernière chance jade
juge à 42 me c'est une enchère
42000 à l'acheteur monsieur votre numéro
d'enchérisseur s'il vous plaît 93 vous
en doutez monsieur c'est bien
22000 sur le lot 69
42 mille
43000 sur le 109 43 milles pour le sang
neuf
non 40 de celles en 42 c'est déjà pris
le premier vous de donner tous les
enchères c'est de bonne guerre en même
temps je viens d'en prendre huit en
voulez-vous à 43 milles monsieur sur 42
mille n'ont pas de 500 ça je peux pas
j'ai déjà coupé les enchères mes cinq
sens je suis pas autorisé 40-40 2000
j'ai refusé d'ailleurs un monsieur tout
à l'heure 1 542 virki collonges un des
quarante deux mille personnes au delà
avoue 42000 numéro 113
on voulait vous d'autres un seul
42 bbc
42000 monsieur combien
non c'est déjà la
personne de couleur chair de 42000
le lot deux suivants jeu 71 42 mille
c'est monsieur c'est le pont neuf
non c'est moi qui prends les enchères
soit 109 j'en prends un
à oui pardon excusez moi c'est 80 j'ai
eu peur non j'ai obligé de prendre des
enchères par tout un stade le sang neuf
à 42000 non non non c'est vous avez
raison vous êtes dans votre rôle 42000
alain pas de problème 43 mille merci
monsieur vous ne souffrez d'un mauvais
pas
43 me
43 mille noms mais monsieur était à 43
me 43 min 6 43 me laisser 40 remy non
j'avais vu monsieur avant c'est non ces
gens que je vois monsieur soyez gentils
c'est les gens que je vois d'abord c'est
monsieur à 43 qui veut derrière nous les
40 44 min 44 milles c'est 44000 pour
vous au fond de la zone qui couvre
longère de 44000 1 44 milles
pas de regret 1 44 milles 1 44 mille
quarante cinq mille merci monsieur à
45000 senti fighters 1 45 milles 1 45 me
pas de regret à 45000 euros adjugée à
vous monsieur 45000 montrant votre
numéro d'enchérisseur
monsieur le 128 45000 mme
[Applaudissements]
lacuey des dames hospitalière la série à
nous sommes à 8000 euros déjà sur
l'annoncé pardon non g dames et
messieurs je donne la parole à aurélie
massou qui va prendre la suite cette
vacation merci beaucoup
[Applaudissements]
mais non
mesdames messieurs bonjour mon nom et
aurélie masse où je suis très heureuse
d'être l'une des commissaires priseurs
de cette vente pour ma première session
de vente je commencerai au lot numéro 72
jusqu'au lot 115 sommes nous prêts s'il
vous plaît en salle des pôvres
aurait dit yes we thank you et nous
allons pouvoir continuer cette vente
avec le lot 72 qui est bonne 1er cru les
grèves cuvée pierre floqué nous aurons
six pièces divisé en trois séries et
pour la première pièce qu'est le numéro
72 débutons directement à 16000 à 16
milles avec vous 17000 devant à 17000
euros 18000
18000 18000 ici devant moi 18000 à 18000
ce avec vous monsieur qui tenait
l'enchère à 18000 euros dans la salle 19
milles plus loin à 19000 site au centre
de la salle à 19000 euros par madame
plupart vous monsieur à 19000 c'est
là-bas à 19000 7 au milieu devant moi à
19000 euros madame c'est vous qui tenez
l'enchère ce n'est pas au téléphone ce
n'est plus vous monsieur à 19000 c'est
en fond de salle au milieu à 19000 euros
et nathan lane à 19000 c'est avec vous
madame et c'est bienvenu à 19000 sans
regret au delà de 19 milles et je vais
adjugé à vous madame à 19000 euros et
c'est bien vu dix neuf mille
à tulle et 19000 votre paddle s'il vous
plaît madame le 176 est-ce que vous
souhaitez également une autre pièce dans
une seule pièce une seule pièce et donc
nous poursuivons avec le 73 maintenant
18 mises directement par vous monsieur
19000 à 19 me sur ma droite à 19000
euros yat-il preneur au delà de 19 mai à
19000 euros pour le 73 à 19000 euros
c'est ici sur ma droite à 19000 euros
c'est sans regret au delà de 19 milles
vingt mille au téléphone avec vous
marianne à 20000 c'est contre vous
monsieur un vingt mille euros c'est
votre enchère marianne au téléphone à en
1906 à rognan bide ils se téléphonent à
20000 euros tout avec vous marianne et
c'est sans regret au delà de vingt mille
ici par vous à 20000 dernière chance à
vingt mille ha du g20 mis l'ol 007
nous poursuivons avec la série b
19000 à 19000 et 20000 ici à droite à
20000 euros maintenant à 20000 par vous
ici devant à 20000 euros par monsieur au
deuxième rang à 20000 euros nous sommes
à 20000 euros et c'est ici et c'est
bienvenu à 20000 sans regret ce n'est
pas au téléphone il note on line à
twenty saisen et stones mick 7 au
deuxième rang ici à 20000 et c'est sans
regret c'est bien vu
adjuger 20000 votre padane messieurs
s'il vous plaît je débute
le paddle numéro 20
souhaitez vous souhaitez vous une autre
pièce seulement celle-ci je vous
remercie et nous poursuivons avec le 75
dix neuf mille à dix neuf mille c'est
très pratique à 19000 euros cette part
vous à 19 mille merci alain à 19000
euros y'a t'il preneur au delà de 19 me
et le 20007 en ligne online à twente 6h
zones urbaines contre vous monsieur à
20000 euros à 20000 euros x online à
20000 euros c'est sur internet à 20000
et c'est bien vu à 20000 à 20000 euros
c'est ici en ligne à 20000 sans regret
en salle à 20 mille euros c'est bien vu
adjuger 20000
118 merci
à 218 ou du like any additional lot
lui avoue en additionnant l'autre outil
de veille le bol où il demande à nadine
haulotte donc nous poursuivons avec le
vingt mille merci beaucoup à 20 milles
devant moi à 20000 euros à 20000 yat-il
preneur au delà de vingt mille euros à
vingt mille euros c'est par vous à vingt
mille euros c'est le long de l'allée à
20000 à 20000 euros et bienvenue à 20000
il y a personne d'autre note on line à
twin sister zone et les fantômes mis à
20000 euros et c'est bien vu
à du g20 me l'a pas 213
il n'y a pas de lots additionnels
disponibles donc nous poursuivons
maintenant avec la série c'est pour le
lot 76
non pardon
77 excusez moi
merci beaucoup heureusement vous êtes
nombreux à vous êtes attentif et pour le
77 des buts 11 à
19 mille mercis à 19000 avec mariana
19000 euros ce n'est pas en salle c'est
au téléphone à 19 villes à 19000 euros
c'est vous qui tenez l'enchère marianne
à 19000 est bienvenue à 19000 à 19000
euros boutonnet l'enchère mariana 19000
euros et c'est bien vu
à 19 mais je vais adjugé faire morning
hadji 19 ni l'ol 007
nous passons à pommard 1er cru les et
peu nos cuvées dont gobelet
nous aurons dix pièces divisé en trois
séries et pour cette première série la
série à
débutons vingt neuf mille cinq cents à
10000 à 11000 euros à 11000 pour le 78
20 mille mercis à 20 milles au premier
rang à 20000 à 25000 euros déjà à 20000
euros 22000 avec vous à 22000 24000 à
24000 26000 à 25000 euros vingt-huit
mille trente mille
à 30000 euros c'est au téléphone avec
vous à 30000 frédéric en voulez-vous à
32 me lauvaux maintenant en ligne ce
titre sa zone online à trente deux mille
euros id sur bide on line à ce titre sa
jeune et c'est bien vu à trente deux
mille cent rio téléphone à 32000 euros
sans regret en salle je vais adjugé à
32000 pour le lot 78
adjugé 32 mille
ou du lac inya du snop sur a10 knox a
envahi le bol
voulez vous des lots additionnels en
ligne des pièces additionnelles ou en
additionnant lot thank you ce qui nous
fait un total de de l'eau douce au total
of tzu locks forme seventy aillent tous
evans nine
et nous arrivons à la pièce numéro 80 et
pour cette piètre 80 20 24000 monsieur
avec vous à 24000 à 24000 26000 au
téléphone 28000 au téléphone
yat-il preneur au delà de 28000 euros
twenty ait thousand sortie sarzeau a
sorti ces zones et au téléphone bi tah
30007 au téléphone à 30000 ce n'est plus
goûteux frédéric à 30 minutes avec vous
à 30 milles c'est bien vu à 30 milles
sans regret au delà de 30 mille
hadj et 30000 ol 00 13
poursuivant avec la série b pour la
première pièce de cette série le lot 81
des boutons à 11000 à 11000 rapidement
vingt-six mille à 26000 contre vous 28
mai le téléphone contre vous monsieur à
28000 trente mille mercis à trente mille
30 2000 par vous à 32 me le deuxième en
trente-deux mille contre vous monsieur à
30 2007 ici à 32000 euros 7 au deuxième
rang ce n'est pas au téléphone à 30 2007
avec vous et c'est bien vu à 32000 sans
regret au delà de 32000 euros et je vais
être jugé ou 32000
adjugé 32 mille ou 20 merci
par pas dole twenty
voulez-vous des pièces additionnelles
monsieur
merci beaucoup nous continuons avec le
82 dans ce cas fall 82
30 mille mercis à 30000 par madame à
30000 ici sur ma droite à 30 milles en
voulez-vous au delà de trente mille
euros avec vous madame à 30 milles et
c'est bienvenu à 30 mille notes online
atlantis à un meeting a sorti sa zone
c'est avec vous madame à 30000 euros et
c'est bien vu à 30 milles sans regret
jade juge a jugé 30000 paddle 89
et nine
voulez vous une autre pièce non
seulement une je vous remercie
poursuivant avec le 83 dans ce cas
trente mille dos devant ici j'ai pris au
fond de la salle avec vous monsieur à
30000 voulez-vous 30 2031 milles si vous
voulez
non sans regret j'ai vu au fond de la
salle avec vous à 30000 à 30 milles
c'est bien vu à 30 milles yat-il preneur
au delà de 30 milles c'est bien vu à 30
milles
sans regret à 30000 jeu les a jugés dans
ce cas à du g30 mélo 45
vous allez pouvoir vous rattraper avec
la série c est le lot numéro 84 30 mille
mercis 30 au mille ici à 30000 32000
contre vous à 32 minutes au téléphone à
32000 euros téléphonent à 32000
maintenant sa petite soeur jeunes et on
the phone a sorti tous à ausone à 32000
euros note online ils se téléphonent
bide à 32000 euros c'est avec votre et
eric à 32000 c'est bien vu c'est bien vu
à 32000 sans regret en salle à 32000
euros
adjugée 32000 ol 00 17
2 merci beaucoup ce sera donc tout à
l'heure chew haïti frenchy five et nous
poursuivons avec le 86 30 mille ici j'ai
vu ici c'est très très rapide à 30 me
avec vous 32 non oui
31 si vous voulez alors trentenaire la
prochaine enchère et de 32000 à trente
et un mille euros ici sur ma gauche
contre vous madame 31 mille euros c'est
ici avec vous au premier rang à trente
et un mille euros sans regret au delà de
31 mille euros c'est bien vu
adjuger 31000 monsieur votre
numéro c'était le 7 merci beaucoup
voulez-vous un autre lot car nous avons
encore un look est disponible
souhaitez vous un seul lot
un je vous remercie et nous
arrivons si je me trompe pas aux 87 30
milles j'ai vu à gauche à trente mille
voulez-vous 31
à 30 mille euros ici en bordure d'allée
je ne peux pas accepter 30200
voulez-vous 31 villes
je n'ai pas pris 500 non plus pour
l'instant je lé prix que 31 villes
voulez-vous 31 villes
31 merci beaucoup madame à 31000 en
bordure d'allée sur ma droite contre
vous monsieur à 31000 ce n'est plus vous
monsieur c'est ici sur ma droite à
trente et un mille euros stevenson
trente et un mille c'est vous qui tenez
l'enchère
sans regret ailleurs en salle à trente
et un mille euros je vais adjugé
adjugé 31 milles
et nous poursuivons avec la série a de
ce vol n'est 1er cru cuvée blandeau 2021
nous aurons dix pièces en dessous en
trois séries abc bien sûr et pour le
premier lot de cette série a le 88
87 ou 120 87 c'est ça
cha soins
et nous arrivons 88
et pour ceux 88 débutons les enchères à
10000 c'est ça dix mille monsieur
20000 à 20000 avec vous 22000 à droite
un vin 2006 à droite à 22000 24000 au
fond à 24 milles au fond 26000 à droite
à 26,7 à droite sur ma droite à 25000
euros yat-il preneur au delà de 26 mille
euros c'est ici sur ma droite pour le 80
vite à 25000 euros c'est bien vu au delà
de 26 mille euros à 26 mille euros ici
sur ma droite note on line in the game à
26 mille euros c'est avec vous ici à
droite et c'est bienvenu à 26000 par
vous merci beaucoup a jugé 26000 au 111
combien de pièces désirez vous une seule
merci beaucoup et nous continuons avec
le lot 89
21 milles devant moi au milieu à 21000
voulez-vous 22000 au fond 22000 22000
euros au fond de la salle avec vous le
58 à 22000 euros
vingt-deux mille
vingt trois mille mercis au téléphone
contre vous 24000
24000 au fond de la salle que dit-on à
24000 25000 25 me contre vous monsieur
sans regret à 25000 c'est sur ma gauche
à 25 mille euros c'est ici au téléphone
à 25000 c'est bien vu à 25000 par vous à
25000 au téléphone
adjugé 25 me l'ol 00 16
ou du lac anonyme just not and we move
en dessous nine si nous arrivons au lot
90 en voulez-vous à 7000 a dit 1000 à
10000 euros avec vous ça vous va à 10000
vingt mille au fond de la salle à 20
milles au fond de la salle 22 milles
devant moi au sang neuf à 22 milles
voulez-vous 26000 24000 au fond à 24
milles avec vous au fond 1 24 milles
c'est vous qui tenez l'enchère au fond
de la salle à 24000 votre enchère à 24
milles c'est vous au fond de la salle
tout au fond de la salle à 24000 je vous
remercie ce n'est pas au téléphone snut
online à 24 milles c'est big town et
d'enchères et je vais à juger maintenant
à 24000
adjugé 24 milles au 88
aux 58 c'était le dernier lot de cette
série
nous passons à la série b
14000 et 15000 par mois à 15000 par mois
ici 16 lille merci à 16000 17000 sur mac
de 18000 par vous à 18000 euros par vous
19 18 milles par vous vingt mille sur ma
gauche 22000 sur ma droite à 22000
21 me à 21 milles par vous au milieu de
la salle à 21000 euros votre enchère au
centre de la salle à 21000 nexis twenty
two thousand la prochaine et de 22000 à
21000 euros c'est par vous au milieu de
la salle 22 mille mercis par vous merci
à 22 milles contre vous monsieur à 22000
voulez-vous 23000
à 22000 c'est votre enchère à 22000
euros sur ma gauche sans regrets au
centre de la salle à 22000 euros
à 22 milles c'est vous sans regret à
c'est ici oui
22000 c'est bien ça à 22000 euros et je
vais être jugée par pour vous à 22
milles il n'y a pas d'autres
enchérisseurs au-delà de 22 mille euros
adulé 22000 c'est le 113
voulez vos des lots additionnels
monsieur non seulement une pièce alors
poursuivons avec le 92 21 milles au
milieu où les 22000 à gauche
à 21,8 centre de la salle à 21 milles 7
milieux ici au centre de la salle à
21000 euros
ici pas vous à 21000 nexis twenty two
thousand à twenty one thousand c'est
dans la salle ici devant moi enfin pas
tout à fait devant moi mais ici à 21000
euros c'est bien vu à 21110 le téléphone
sans regrets sur ma droite à 21000 euros
au fond de la salle c'est bien vu à
dernière chance
adjé 21000
2 pour le sang neuf merci beaucoup et
nous terminons cette série tout ou en
additionnant le lot
et nous passons à la série c'est 18
milles sur ma gauche 19 mai laufon 21
mai la droite 21000 à droite ici à 21000
euros maintenant à 21 milles sur la
droite à 21 milles à 21000 euros c'est
bien vu à 21
derrière chance à 21000 euros c'est ici
et je vais adjugé à 21 milles sans
mobile au téléphone sans maugréer sur
internet à 21 milles c'est bien vu
adjuger 21000
c'est vous
114 et vous en prenez 3 3 pièces ce qui
nous ce qui fait que nous terminons
cette série c'est avec vous monsieur
corton grand cru clos du roy cuvée
baronne du baÿ nous aurons trois pièces
est tout d'abord la série à
et pour ce lot des buts on a vingt mille
2,97 à 20000 contre vous 22000 24000
25000 26000 par mois à vingt-six mille
euros c'est mon enchères vingt-huit
mille trente mille trente mille 30 2035
1038 mis 48 45
1050 merci à 50,55 par mois 55 sur ordre
nexis sixty
55 par mois
55 ses mandants cher
56 à 56 avec dix à cinquante six mille
euros à 56 la prochaine et de 57000 as
57 mille pardons mario contre vous 58
merci
1,58 voulez-vous 59 mario à 58000 sait
où
un 50e et 59 en ligne contre vous voulez
vous 60
à 59 milles 6 finalistes online testing
and its online the game chaucer contre
vous monsieur
60-60 voulez-vous 61 mario à 60 mille
euros c'est vous qui tenez l'enchère 61
en ligne contre eux
à 61 minutes online leader patrick
stewart et 6,6 one thousand simons
ithurbide soeur online à 61
1061 que dit-on mario je vous attends à
61 milles
l'enchère est en ligne pour le 97
sans regret alors je vais adjugé à 61
milles sans regret monsieur
je vous remercie à 61 me laissait bien
vu yat-il preneur au delà de 61000
dernière chance sixt je n'accepte pas
les sens
je vous remercie 61000 vous allez
pouvoir vous rattraper c'est que steve
hansen irbid online and selling
adjugé 61 milles
l'enchérisseur
série b pour cette pièce 98 nous
débutons les enchères
rapidement à 22 24 26 28 30 milles à
30000 euros trente deux mille trente
cinq mille à
38,50 merci 55 par mois à 55 c'est moins
cher ici sur entre fifty-five attriste
ifag sarzeau
56 57 mario voulez-vous 57 à 56 1000
euros par vous 57 merci 57 au téléphone
contre vous monsieur 58
à 58,59 massy
58 59 sur ma droite à 59 mille soixante
mille contre vous monsieur
61 massy à 61,7 et vous en salle note
online at six teams newby
contre vous madame à 62 mille soixante
trois mille en ligne six titres ea
online à 6tu suite gagne ou mario et en
live à 63000 euros ce n'est plus vous
madame à 63000
irbid online natixis suit thousand à
6,18 la science mario at 6 18
à 63 me laissait bien juge
fernand ning
63100 regret à 63000 adjé 63000 aux 264
pour cette série c'est le lot 99 qui me
donne 50 milles qui me donne 50 milles
pour ce lot 50 55 par mois 55 moins cher
ici sur ordres fictifs à un vitrail
commisssion bits ou du lag sixty
sexting fio à 60000 euros qu'on trouve
ses filles au téléphone
soixante-trois mille soixante trois
mille contre vous marionnettiste 64000
la prochaine est de 64 mille euros nous
sommes à 63000 avec vous 64 merci
64000 europe à vous monsieur pas vous
madame à 64000 ci contre vous 65
65 mille euros de nouveau au centre aux
bords de l'allée à 60
66000 c'est vous
à droite à 66 mille euros sexy
667 de nouveau par vous madame à 67000
monsieur que fait-on à 67000 ce n'est
pas vous qui tenez l'enchère c'est vous
madame à 67000 en bordure d'allée sépare
vous à 67000 monsieur que dit-on il me
faut une réponse d'accord j'attends un
petit peu alors 60 7000 euros pour
l'instant atik style sixties seventies
donne à 67000 68000 c'est le problème
d'attendre
68000 online at sexy and thousands
online contre vous madame voulez-vous
à 68000 ici l'enchère est en ligne
orbite online at 6 y ait thousands
69 mille mercis à 69 milles de nouveaux
noms
70000 je vous remercie à 70,26 hardened
à 106 1 once in the remix nature de
l'année et se gagnent au à 70000 euros
c'est votre enchère à 70000 euros
yat-il preneur au delà de 70 mille
online ou du lac to build your head of
6,26 à ausone à 70000 euros ce n'est pas
votre enchère et ce games online à 70000
euros c'est ici et c'est bienvenu à 70
milles sans regret au delà de 70 mille
euros c'est bien vu ici par vous faire
morning
adjugé 70 milles
votre numéro merci beaucoup 89e
félicitations
89 haïti nine
mazis chambertin grand cru cuvée
madeleine collignon nous allons vendre
14 pièce est une feuille est divisé en
cinq séries séries a b c d et e du
débutant avec la série à
et pour cette série j'ai déjà preneur à
40 42 45 1000 contre 1 45 mille euros 48
50 55 à 55 milles et 60000 65000 ici
déjà preneur à 65 me contre vous 70000
80000 80 me sur ma droite 85000 85 mais
quatre-vingt dix mille cent mille mercis
à 100000 euros devant moi à 100 mille
cent dix mille au fond de la salle à 110
n'hésite au fond de la salle contre 1
110 110 milles c'est en fond de salle à
110000 euros
cent vingt mille mercis à 120 milles
contre vous au fond de la salle à 120
milles ce téléphone à 120000 euros
maintenant
voilà doit être twenty thousand with
mario and the phone à 120000 euros sur
ma gauche au téléphone à 120 milles
c'est sans regret au fond de la salle à
120000 euros maintenant l'enchère est
avec mario téléphone et c'est bien vu à
dernière chance au delà
220000 euros avec mario tchad juge
adjé 120000 ol 0 0 12
nous avons deux lots supplémentaires qui
sont disponibles mario souhaitez-vous
des lots additionnels
nous allons patienter un instant car la
ligne est coupée je vous demandais un
tout petit peu de patience messieurs
dames s'il vous plaît
le temps de savoir si nous vendons la
totalité de cette série ou si nous
poursuivons
si vous souhaitez boire un verre d'eau
c'est le moment
envoyé un message
voilà donc nous sommes au lot numéro 100
on passe uniquement le lot sans noah 10
no lot merci beaucoup maintenant on se
reconcentre avec la pièce numéro 101 la
pièce numéro 101 et j'ai déjà 60 et 65
milles contre vous 70 mille soixante
quinze mille cent mille sur ma droite à
cent mille 100 disparus madame 120 merci
120 1000e euros au milieu de la salle
120000 par vous ici monsieur à 120000
euros
yat-il preneur au delà de 120 milles à
120000 euros maintenant
à 120000 euros en bordure d'allée ici
devant moi à 120 milles et c'est bien vu
un cent vingt mille sans regret au delà
220000 euros note hugh lane it's in the
room à guangzhou et shenzhen à 120000
euros ici et c'est bien vu à 120000
hadj et 120 mille ha
vous prenez un lots additionnels ce qui
fait un total de 2 pièces est ce que je
peux avoir votre numéro d'enchérisseur
113 merci mon nom doit dentsu lot hinton
nous poursuivons avec la série b pour la
première pièce de cette série qui est le
sens troyes débutons hague 120 milles
sur ma droite à 120 et 130 mille ici
devant contre vous à 130 milles c'est
devant moi à 130000 ici devant moi à 130
milles à 130000 euros y'a t'il preneur
au delà de 130 mille one and zen sorti
thousand votre enchère ici au premier
rang à 130 milles et c'est bien vu à 130
milles c'est sans regret au delà de 130
mille
dernière chance à 130000 le marteau
tombe
adjugée 130000
aux 150 2 souhaitez vous combien de
pièces souhaitez vous madame
only one thing you
know additionnant lot
nous poursuivons maintenant avec le 104
avec 100000 120
130 130 à droite à 130 milles 7 à droite
cent trente mille euros maintenant à 130
milles c'est pas par vous alors 120
excusez-moi mois de nouvelles toiles 620
vous devant par vous de vents à 120 130
contre vous en fond de salle contre voix
130 sans regrets alors un cent trente
mille euros en fond de salle maintenant
c'est vous qui tenez l'enchère au fond
de la salle à 130000
signé james ce téléphone on line à
130000 euros au fond de la salle merci
pour vos enchères monsieur à 130 milles
c'est bien vu sans regret à 130000
hadj et 130 mille ha
votre numéro de paddle s'il vous plaît
si l'ip s'il vous plaît votre
enchérisseurs au fond de la salle à 130
milles
sur la sur la gauche
alors 125 en
whisenhunt twenty five ah si tu as toi
ne doit d'antoine si five à 125000 au
rouge je vais devoir accepter des
enchères supplémentaires s'il y en a
cent trente mille cent trente mille
euros contre vous monsieur
j'avais compris que vous étiez à 130
milles au fond de la salle donc je ré
ouvre à 130000 euros maintenant c'est à
droite voulez-vous surenchérir au delà
de 130 mille euros en fond de salle
à 130000 euros c'est à droite
c'est bien vu à 130 milles pour le lot
numéro 104
c'est bien vu à 130 milles sans regret
en fond de salle à 130000
hd 130000
paddle number s'il vous plaît votre
numéro
alors je n'en ai qu'un qui est
disponible un an pardon excusez moi bien
sûr de donc 104 et 105 c'est bien ça je
vous remercie en additionnant le lot
nous arrivons à la série s'est pour la
première pièce de cette série
le 106 commençons à 35000 40 me à droite
1 50 milles au téléphone 120 à 120000
maintenant 130000 en fond de salle 1 130
mist en fond de salle c'est vous au fond
de la salle à 130 milles c'est bien ça
sur ma gauche à 130 milles 1 130 mille
euros au fond de la salle sur ma gauche
ce n'est pas un milieu c'est en fond de
salle sur ma gauche
c'est bien vu à 130000 euros maintenant
au fond de la salle c'est bien par vous
au fond de la salle à 130 milles c'est
sans regret ailleurs à 130000 euros ce
n'est pas au téléphone ce n'est pas en
ligne 1 130 milles 7 au fond de la salle
et c'est bienvenu à 130 milles sans
boguey sur ma droite
sans regret en ligne à 130 milles c'est
au fond de la salle et c'est bien vu
dernière chance
jay 130000 aux 85
est ici five tu combien de pièces voulez
vous monsieur
juste une merci beaucoup
poursuivons avec le numéro 107 120 120
130 à droite à 130 milles à droite
148 nos téléphones avec vos jamie à 140
milles c'est vous qui tenez l'enchère à
140 milles
non 137 et en salle à 137 et en salle à
137 et en salle voulez-vous 140000 au
téléphone à 130 milles
est-ce que l'enchérisseur à 130 milles à
droite deux mois pourrait se manifester
s'il vous plaît
merci beaucoup c'était là c'était par
vous merci à 130000
voulez-vous enchérir au delà de 130
milles au téléphone jamie hince no 1 130
mille euros c'est par vous le paddle
numéro 75 assez bien vu à 130 sans
regret au delà de 130 mille euros ici
par vous à 130 milles sur ma droite la
science jade juge ici maintenant à
130000 euros aux 75
adjugé 130000
paddle 75 combien de pièces voulez vous
monsieur juste une merci
nous continuons avec
130 130 pardoux à 130
120 en 137 est au téléphone avec vous
marianne c'est ça
130 merci à 120 milles et à 130 milles
avec vous un cent trente mille euros en
salle à 130 milles
130 mille euros c'est en salle est bien
vu au delà de 130 mille ici
devant moi à 130000 euros - ne doit
donne satisfaction à 130000 euros sans
regret au téléphone sans regret à 130
milles merci beaucoup un cent trente
mille euros ici par vous dernière chance
sur ma droite dernière chance au fond de
la salle à 130 milles
à 230 milles au centre est
[Applaudissements]
voulez vous des lots additionnels
monsieur
combien de pièces voulez vous uniquement
une pièce je pense
uniquement une pièce vous avez encore
une autre pièce qui est disponible juste
une je vous remercie
et pour le lot 109,2 débutons à
120-130 à 130 avec vous de juillet à 130
votre enchère jimmy choo à 130000 euros
c'est vous qui tenez l'enchère à 130000
euros y'a t'il preneur au delà de 130
mille à 130000 euros c'est au téléphone
et ce téléphone been at wanadoo est
sorti thousand 1 130 mille euros
maintenant ce n'est pas par vous ici par
vous à droite à 138 c'est vous qui tenez
l'enchère jamie 1 130 milles et c'est
bien vu
dernière chance à 130000
adjugé 130000 ol 0 0,25
c'était le dernier lot de cette série c
nous arrivons à la série dès
la première pièce de cette série c'est
le numéro 110 120 mille cent vingt mille
sur ma gauche au téléphone à 120 milles
qui me dit 130 à 120000 euros ici avec
vous marianne à 120 milles 1 120 mille
euros que dit-on 100-125
125 par vous voulez vous 130000 marianne
1 125 mille euros
1 125 1000 euros par vous à droite
125 mille euros
ici à 125
que dit-on au delà de 125 à 125 mille
euros ici sur ma droite
130 en ligne soit en inde ouadane sortie
tron live contre vous monsieur à 130
milles
130 milles que dit-on à 130 milles c'est
contre vous sur ma droite à 130000 euros
c'est en ligne sur internet à 130000
dernière chance au delà de 130 mille
c'est bien vu à 130 milles sans regret
en salle sur ma droite ici à 130000
euros c'est sur internet
dernière chance à 130 milles
à douze et cent trente mille
paddle 264 ou du like any additional
l'auteur online
hu a fui additional lot which are
available
que dit on s'il vous plaît sur internet
1 130 mille euros pour le lot numéro 110
voulez-vous des droits additionnels au
delà de 130 mille noah 10 no lot 5 ue et
nous continuons avec le lot numéro
111 à cent mille cent vingt mille sur ma
gauche 130 milles à droite non 120
milles sur ma gauche un cent vingt mille
ici avec vous marianne à 120 milles sans
regret sur ma droite sans regret sur
internet à 120000 ici par vous êtes
manager est n 106 thousand à 120 mille
euros c'est votre enchère marianne
120000 ce n'est pas en salle et ce n'est
pas sur internet cette fois à
vingt mille euros mon agent one si la
science online at one world one twenty
thousand ce téléphone beats et au
téléphone ici sur ma gauche avec vous
marianne sans regret à 120000
adjugé 120000
ol 0 02
voulez vous combien de pièces
voulez-vous marianne
vous avez deux pièces qui sont
disponibles si vous le souhaitez pas de
lots supplémentaires je vous remercie
noah disney lot et nous poursuivons avec
le 112 à cent mille euros pour le 112
assemble 10120
1120 par vous ici au faux bords de
l'allée à 120 mille
cent vingt mille euros c'est vous tenez
l'enchère ce n'est pas d'un téléphone
cent vingt mille ici par vous dans
l'allée à 120 milles et c'est bien vu
sans regret au delà de 120 mille euros
c'est ici en bordure d'allée à 120000
l'ac100 dernière chance ici à 120000
euros
adjugée 120000 aux 64
il ya encore un lot qui est disponible
si vous le souhaitez combien de pièces
voulez-vous juste une je vous remercie
et nous avons donc la pièce 113 qui que
nous pour lesquelles nous commençons les
enchères à 100 milles à 100 milles qui
me dit 110 mille cent dix mille noms
cent mille euros contre vous 110000 à
droite merci à 110000 euros sur ma
droite maintenant 120 milles en ligne on
doit d'être ici en live band ouadane
twenty thousands online à 120000 euros
ce n'est plus vous sur ma droite
donc et nous revenons à 110000 euros ici
par vous à droite à 110000 euros
cent dix mille
cent quinze mille pardons 120 milles
contre vous maintenant
voulez-vous 125000
its online athmane guadal twenty
thousand
sur internet à 120000 euros
contre vous monsieur à 120 milles et
bien vu à 120 milles et c'est maintenant
sur internet à 120000 dernière chanson
sale à 120000 euros x online c'est par
vous enchérisseurs qui est sur internet
à 120 mille euros c'est vous qui tenez
l'enchère c'est sans regret sur ma
droite et je vais adjugé 120000 euros
adjugée 120000
c'était le paddle 261 sous un jet l6
timone et c'était le dernier lot de
cette série
nous arrivons au lot numéro 114 est une
feuille est pour cette feuillatte
débutons les enchères à 20000 à 20000 à
25000 maintenant à 22000 qui 12h24 il
sur ma droite à 24000 26000 ici à 26 ici
devant mon à 28000 28000 contre vous
contre vous à 28 milles c'est vous qui
tenez enchères 20 ans trente mille 30 me
sur ma droite 32000 en ligne
35000 par aussi vous voulez 35 mille
mercis 1 35 milles contre vous sur ma
droite 38 mines ici sur ma droite
quarante mille contre vous derrière vous
à 48,40 en 2000 au téléphone 1,42 les
45000 par vous contre vous le téléphone
un 45000 euros maintenant
48 milles
par vous à 48 mille voulez-vous
enchaîner derrière à 48 mille euros
48000 euros sur ma droite cinquante
mille contre vous sur internet à 50
minutes
cinquante mille euros c'est sur internet
ce n'est plus vous sur ma droite à 50000
euros x online à 50 milles
55 mille pardons à 55000 60000 euros
maintenant hâte sixty thousand à 6,6
hors zone sixty five à 65000 euros en
ligne sur internet à soixante cinq mille
euros vous voulez vous enchaînez au delà
de 65 mille non sans regret à 65000
euros
sixty five thousand its own la natte
sixty five thousand à 65000 euros et son
regret en salle sans regret au téléphone
à
65000 euros
et je vais adjugé à 65 me
65000 sans regret plus vous madame à 65
milles 7 en ligne et jade juge à 65
milles
sur le marteau parle 70 je n'ai pas dit
adjugé 70 mille euros par jour merci
bout par bout à 70 milles on verra mais
rate ses 26 ans zone and my ride à 106
aaron c'est sur ma droite ici à 70
milles
c'est même si ça aux home games online à
106,1 zone in the room sur le marteau
pardon monsieur à 70000 euros
ou du lac sévan tu files voulez-vous
75000 euros en ligne à ses 26 à ausone
iobit soeur votre enchère ici devant
vous devant moi pardon à 70000 euros
last shot online à 126 thousand in the
home games show à 70000 euros le marteau
tombe à 70000
adjugé au 114
70 mille euros
114 - en guadeloupe anne fortier
et nous arrivons maintenant au lot
numéro 115 l'eau particulièrement
attendu puisqu'il s'agit bien sûr de la
pièce des présidents
[Musique]
c'est parfait mais c'est là que c'est
parti à faire chauffer entre erevan et
partir des tchats ses parts au lancement
c'est parfait on accueille la mère de
mollesse à l'école
[Musique]
c'est bon voilà mesdames et messieurs
nous allons donc procéder maintenant à
la mise en vente de la pièce des
présidents qui est encore temps renard
de grands crus au profit de nobles
causes importantes
solidarité femmes représentées par ma
voisine jeanne balibar et puis bien sûr
l'institut curie qui était déjà chez
nous ya six ans
toujours pour la cause du combat contre
le cancer notamment le cancer du sein
cette année donc représenté par pio
marmaï
mesdames messieurs comme il est d'usagé
à la vente des vins ce sont nos
présidents qui recevront vos enchères et
qui donneront le coup de marteau final
on vous rejoins rejoint pas chaleur
pixels et allez-y les don additionnel
merci beaucoup
non c'est pas son coup peut-être dire un
petit mot sur les sur les organismes que
le planton oui si vous je prends la
parole
déjà bonjour mesdames et messieurs je
voulais déjà remercié évidemment la
ville de beaune les auspices les équipes
techniques on peut aussi à peu dire
l'équipe sotheby's
merci à vous les cours cométaire mais
j'ai l'impression que seuls 13 plutôt
pas mal je voulais tout d'abord vous
dire à quel point je suis fier et la
molette le président à côté de jeanne de
la 161e vente des hospices de beaune est
particulièrement fière aussi de
représenter l'institut curie pour des
raisons qui me sont intimement personnel
chaque année ce sont près de soixante
mille femmes qui sont atteintes du
cancer du sein et 2000 en meurent le
cancer du sein est la deuxième cause de
mortalité par cancer chez la femme
juste après le cancer du poumon plus que
jamais nous avons besoin de vous les
cocos
car la recherche c'est l'espoir de
trouver de nouveaux traitements alors
j'en appelle à votre générosité mesdames
et messieurs c'est parti on démarre
encore trois petites secondes pillot
jeudi comme toi merci à tout le monde et
je ne répète pas ce que tu as dit si
bien dit pour moi et pour toi et pour
tout ça
chers amis voilà ça y est ça commence
enfin on en parle enfin on peut en
parler les langues se délient pour
toutes sortes de raisons ça veut dire
que cette année cette fois ci on a une
chance historique nouvelle d'apporter de
l'aide à toutes les femmes qui crient
pour en avoir et qui n'en reçoivent pas
il y à une de mes amies qui un jour cet
effet ouvrir le crâne par la personne
avec qui elle vivait elle a appelé sa
mère sa mère lui a dit qu'est ce que tu
veux ma fille il ya des hommes qui sont
comme ça elle a appelé son père et lui a
dit je m'en fous je vais le raconter lui
a dit non non non non ma fille ces
choses là ne doivent pas sortir de la
maison et de la famille et bien si
maintenant elle sorte et pour aider les
femmes à partir à être accueillis à
trouver un hébergement à trouver une
aide juridique il faut du personnel
formé chaque poste coûte 50 mille euros
par an on y va
allez messieurs dames c'est à l'école ça
démarre fort fort fort
un régal au
premier rang chez les buts et nous
allons débuter maintenant alors nous
débutons à 100000 euros rapidement à
100000 euros cent mille c'est pipeau
c'est vraiment ses premières enchères ça
démarre au mou du cul 100000 ses
partisans- monde messieurs nathan les
cent mille cinq cent mille euros c'est
rien 110 mille cent vingt mille heures
de mal et 120 kg pousse on pousse on
pousse à 120 mille tonnes en charge est
de 130 mille cent trente mille six cent
trente mille autres vous man à 130
millions c'est pas du bordeaux c'est du
bourgogne on avance allait on avance on
avance on avance voulez-vous cent
cinquante cent cinquante à cent
cinquante mille euros c'est vous à 158 à
cent cinquante 150 mille euros c'est un
téléphone 160 au téléphone philippe au
fond dit moins bons chiffres philippe
regarde moi quand je parle philippe très
bien aller vous l'avez vu au fond de la
salle à 160 milles aller plus loin elle
et défendez vous c'est un mec derrière
langue il travaille à lausanne 80
millions latin compos sont poussés pour
le cancer c'est pour le papa tu sortais
je nettoie on est parti en avance à la
pause
au contraire sa cote enfants matin deux
cents mille deux cent mille euros à
gosselies le haut il en manque encore
quelque chose et mon 400 mille deux cent
vingt mille euros sont la fin monsieur
le préfet à 500 me j'ai l'impression
juste là n'ont oublié ou 20000 euros à
droite on pousse à les 230 milles cessa
de centre de 130000 c'est les
clopinettes on avance on avance on
avance au téléphone il se passe des
choses à
240 milles au fond de la salle 246 50
250 devant moi contre vous mariez
260 au fond de la salle 260 je rappelle
que le fruit du microscope ses 700
milles on en est loin avant son avance
en avant du der et messieurs là il ya du
bon dans cette salle où pas bien du
mouloud à
320 milles au fond de la femme sur ma
droite ici vous l'avez vu à 320 milles
euros ses fils qui avaient d'abord où tu
te caches philippe sansfaçon 1350
350 305 m nicole
358 john
étroite enquête pendant au fond de la
salle j'ai vu ses bienfaits à 390 mois
180 milles ça commence à chauffer ça
commence à choper le soleil pour les
stones 400 lits le sol se transformant
la nationale 4 ans lille on peut encore
pousser apple
est-ce 420000 au fond de la salle 420
1978 j'ai un petit job
450 450 458
480000 je rappelle que le receleur
autant et de 600000 on peut l'atteindre
mais cela non pas par mille cinq cent
mille cinq cent mille avons encore 108
messieurs dames c'est maintenant que ça
joue c'est la prospérité c'est ma tante
a trouvé cela dans la tête
il montre entrant en ville qui est ce
qui va et vient sur la table et sans vie
raisonnable et ce poney dehors de
paulette année tout pas y aperçoit qui
répond on s'en fout rien n'avance allez
c'est parti on continue à 500 me ici
devant moi 5 500 mille cinq cent mille
cinq cent mille cinq cent mille au
téléphone il a un truc avec le fils
qu'est ce qui dit au bout du fil le mec
nicolas champ chez le ch est à l'italien
schwazer factor j'ai alors l'état visant
nilmar et mon pote sûrement un bon
chiffre 520000 y arrive - au moins 520
aller s'installer en moins
allez monsieur le préfet mais rien cent
mille euros
à 500 mille euros ça sent 1500 vie c'est
pas mal quand même à avancer c'est
l'approché d'un million la très bien
être à l'arrêt c'est pas y aller ça
pourrait être la mâchoire qui peut on y
va cinq cent mille euros pour l'instant
que dit ou sa santé je sais qu'il est un
peu dur il ya eu la moitié fou et enfin
la salle enfin la salle que dit-on au
delà de 500 mille cinq cent mille 500 me
c'est quand même mieux c'est quand même
du bon vin je veux dire
la finale c'est quand même un bon voyez
la bombe ou un celi 20e bon goût à 500
mille balles le tonneau ça fait 300
bouteilles se laissant le cas qu on va
demander à philippe inutile regarde
quand je parle il s'en fout complètement
ok c'est parti on continue 500 milles
qui vit 520 5 120 à 160 milles euros
pour l'instant à 500 mille euros et nous
pouvons faire plus que cinq cent mille 1
500 mille euros
c'est déjà beaucoup je vous le jeu vous
le reconnaît attelé allez allez
allez plus que cela plus ensemble et
c'est pas mal ça en fait un bon paquet
bouteille 500 blessés par allons petit 1
520 ya paramètres le pouls des filles en
asie je ne sais pas
l'asie c'est foutu tout est foutu est-ce
que la juda s'attendent il
je crois qu'on apprend du coup de
marteau je crois qu'on approche du coup
de marteau la bougie est encore là elle
n'est pas ton corps et cheveux après
nous allons pouvoir réponses qu'est ce
que c'est que ce truc là c'est une
bougie tu veux jouer ensuite je suis 1
500 amis je me brûle le bras on y va
vous êtes prêts un parcours 20 milles de
plus je me boulevard vous n'êtes pas
d'habits balle 500 braila 10 550 550 la
veille par jean miot bull vous n'êtes
pas je brûle je fais super mal on
continue on est à 550 en avant son
contenu de ces partis roda sa peau
dure pas
[Applaudissements]
580 on est atteint 1000 euros du rotois
messieurs dames sabrina tôt il reste pas
vu le rocher s'étend sur 320 40 euros à
lille ryback 3000 euros mais seul un
valley l'euro pour entre la prospérité
pour la postérité pour n'est pas battu
pour la lutte contre le cancer
hachez vie tu as les 580 fond de la
salle au fond de la salle à 304 au fond
de la salle un sa fin car au fond de la
salle 180 c'est pas malin à 580 et sa
relance la course
590 180 580
ils mangent du maître d'armes en trombe
si j'avais eu envie
29,6 en ville on veut savoir on a battu
le record n'a pris de bec on adore
six cent mille
six cent mille euros pour 300 bouteilles
de rouge je te laisse faire le calcul
s'est passé au fond de la salle et nous
attendons on va prendre un petit peu de
temps là je pense prenez temps pub et un
coup d'argent les pulls à wisques aider
la personne qui sert le dans la cipressa
font
attention attention y tue téléphone
qu'est-ce-qui d'italiens c'est mort ça
fait 8 alors que tu fais semblant de
téléphoner ça commence à fatiguer mon
pote annonces soient les bonnes
nouvelles tu me sors 1,6 en lice 1 620
mais j'ai pas que ça à allez on
avance s'ils sont amis toujours mais
cela faisait cent mille fois dans
ses 22 buts et
d'allison il
s'est battu c'est ça la cie sera
pourtant santon 18 ans marine
hérétique
attention mais cela mon rond on est déjà
dans l'histoire toute façon un enfant de
la salle à 600 ou lala lala 620 c'est
pas mal est ce qu'on peut faire tout
seul
on peut aussi faire des lots de
consolation des dîners des petits repas
des trucs comme ça des jeux pour pour
trente mille ballons sans rendez-vous à
pizza pino là sur le sur les champs
elysées s'est ouvert à ton petit ballon
la pâte à l'heure on assiste en valais
toujours toujours s'en va c'est pas mal
hein toujours au fond de la salle 6 ans
rami
c'est sa propre à puteaux
m6 en calant 640 kg le 278 quand il le
veut libé rentrer dans l'histoire
nationale 648 euros 640 milles
[Applaudissements]
500-600 sagan pizza
650 plus évident 50 millimes ces
serpents par 660 et sa dame ça n'arrête
pas de rentrée
ça ne rate a noté hervé oui si on n'y a
rien dont nous les babouches rouler ou
ici ou là
et ça continue ma petite 600 soit
en pid aller ça pousse je suis épuisée
je suis épuisé ses yeux je suis épuisé
on n'avait pas fini truc j'ai lâché
faire une syncope suis-je dans la
réalité aller 666 pas mal on peut
peut-être pas tant le fait de son vélo
680 quelque chose
le rockeur est battu 1 c'est bon alors
là je vais dire comment il s'appelle la
loutre la qualité d'être au coeur la
lekie iron chez ta mère c'est pour la
gagner on l'a on a battu un essai on a
laissé au 671 actions continuent à
avancer on continue la machine est
lancée mais chez dame on pousse on
pousse le téléphone via pas la lacetti
quelque chose j'aurais dû tout littell
ils ont toujours 1
[Applaudissements]
670 son pote
ok c'est là tout le monde aimerait s'y
connaissent la 690 euros
au
bilan 80000 euros par bce ont atteint
690 drew
700000 euros mais senna je viens de
l'entendre 710 juste là sept cent mille
euros mais cela ne
cette combine
sept cent mille sept cent mille mais
cela 710 720
1720 by pour le sont sans danger 700 à
1000 euros ga presse comme ça ne
s'arrêtera jamais j'ai fait une syncope
acier de 550 je fais de 50 me dont
720 mille euros mais cela excuse moi je
n'arrête pas de jacqueline je t'en prie
t
il fait tellement bien
alors 720000 je ne savais plus quoi dire
là j'ai tout épuisé le préfet il est
visé à l'aimer c'est la route at-on les
mains à l'électro noir allez donc
pouvoir aussi dehors je vous vois sur la
trace mais c'est la tablette ou entendu
report en tremblant mécénat pour le
cancer on les a battus
c'est bon vous faites dans la nuit mais
se rattrape toujours c'est mon avis et
c'est des choses et c'est quelque chose
et c'est des choses simplement et c'est
quelque chose qui siège au sk quelque
chose et ce quelque chose si la sortie
on discute alice culte avait plus fort
mais pas plus bas
ça discute ça discute ça discute ça
puisqu'il fait les sculpteurs
quelque chose
730 kg nationale jeanne a raconté je
vous l'avais dit c'est sur des pistes
onic cette occasion
sept cent quarante mille sept cent
quarante mille c'est extraordinaire cet
encart en pile là ça commence à être
limite pour m'a fait trop un moi je
trouve que c'est roger kahane évidemment
c'est pas assez dans l'odieux
748 messieurs lamont là haut on respire
on prend cinq secondes l'un d'eux
devrait surtout pour moi
741 40000 on respire un petit peu à 715
films c'est encore un pénis passe
quelque chose il se passe quelque chose
pourquoi tout le monde est debout parce
que ce moment est historique au parent
est ce qu'il est historique ce moment
oui les
en mémoire de monsieur jacquet
750000 euros mais se donne
alors la
défaite
en
1766 je l'attend 760 milles au fond le
178 il en a une grosse paire celui ci
est un sacré ce portefeuille dit
ça n'est pas qu'avec sylvain de livres
les abos on avance on avance
avec lui qu'une bougie
1768 c'est un gâchis 60000 euros au fond
de la salle à
760 milles bientôt depuis 2000 dans le
micro va falloir va falloir avancer
parce que moi il va falloir taper le mât
faut imaginer la vente des vins après
vous allez vous faire chier comme des
rajouts lui alors là ça va être un chien
enfin bref c'est pas mon problème
760 760 1000 à 700 face c'est quand même
quelque chose hein ça commençait pas mal
est-ce qu'on laisse qu'on ne serait pas
[Applaudissements]
cette l'empattement dans 1700 m
c'est ton père
[Applaudissements]
puis ça me touche 178 directement
800000 pour l'instant prix sont
1800 milles c'est dabbashi
on les leur présent piot tu n'es pas en
train de rêver huit cent mille un moyen
fort ça s'arrête à 800 milles est en
fait le calcul d'heures à 300 goûter il
ya un peu de perte 1 ça fait quoi si ou
lé jeu passera alors huit cent mille à
8 00 000 à 800 milles euros et c'est un
chiffre extraordinaire ici je pense que
c'est pas mal hein c'est pas leur corps
très bien je pense que ça on s'en fout
complètement éclaté alors 800 milles
alors 800 me leroy dame est ce que vous
voudriez appelé smart genre jeanne s'il
vous plaît
alors ni cent mille euros à 800 milles
euros
1 800 2000 euros maintenant est ce que
voulait dire une fois deux fois trois
fois
allez-y je vous en prie
il faut taper
oui tout à fait oui tout à fait
par exemple
et
mussolini
malraux bastonnade l'institut curie pour
merci
merci à tous de nous lui devons beaucoup
et je veux vous lancer
à nouveau à la tribune
elmer symons
maintenant
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]
oui
huawei
[Applaudissements]
il faut que l'acheteur de rejoindre bien
évidemment à des tribunes
[Musique]
labbé
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]
m
[Applaudissements]
de même c'est quelque chose
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
on arrive
[Musique]
tous
on peut applaudir mais seul arbre
huit cent mille euros pour cela
nationale des femmes et l'institut curie
cet historique
bonsoir iv
walchhofer son taux grecs en relation
entre michael et directeur
du groupe
et que les fondamentaux look after
d'ipad est le nom de ces mots pour
chelsea women now in this moment
un
fournisseur primé rigole toujours forte
all of the people the need it
j'ai essayé de courir en france est ce
que mon ami mattia ady
nous sommes un jeune groupe qui est
basée à londres qui s'occupe de vendre
des vins à ses fins en particulier des
bourgognes nous achetons des hospices de
beaune tous les ans depuis quatre ans
la cause des femmes est très importante
pour notre groupe parce que nous avons
beaucoup de femmes qui travaillent des
femmes extraordinaires nous sommes très
proches des idées de ce qui vient d'être
discutée par jeanne balibar et par
monsieur je me rappelle plus votre
marmaille j'habite près en france depuis
longtemps donc avec l'excusé mois mais
et moi ça me touche tout
particulièrement parce que ma mère a eu
un cancer du sein n'y a pas très
longtemps donc c'est très important donc
merci beaucoup pour votre soutien nous
on est là pour vous aider on a essayé de
faire de notre mieux aujourd'hui car si
nous avoir fait rire d'amiens c'était
très drôle et bonne continuation c'est
pas fini c'est pas fini
[Applaudissements]
c'est
mesdames et messieurs nous allons
poursuivre cette vente s'il vous plaît
et j'ai l'honneur d'accueillir ma
consoeur aurélie vente de vin merci
beaucoup
je
non